we're very excited about our next guest
who is known for tackling serious issues
with a lot of Comedy Hassan minhaj was a
correspondent on The Daily Show before
getting his own show Patriot Act which
is fantastic by the way now he's out
with a new comedy special on Netflix
called The King's gesture in it minhaj
talks about fatherhood social media
cloud and an anthrax scare after he made
Saudi Arabia's government angry the show
starts with minhaj opening up about
struggles with infertility in the tough
conversation he had with his wife BINA
anyone going through fertility problems
you know it loads the relationship
all this pressure you know
me and Bina we'd be up late at night
having these really tough conversations
you know it's just gonna happen for us
are we gonna be able to have kids
and then I was like babe what if we
adopt
what if we adopt a white baby just to
flex on these
[Music]
just to show people we made it you know
what I mean reverse Angelina Jolie power
move rather Bradley run that's the
ultimate Flex right there
towards us right now
um good morning how you doing oh man
thanks for having me I'm excited to be
here of course so
um you were able to fix uh the
infertility uh problems that you speak
about yes and for the record we have a
brown baby yeah a brown baby okay yeah
he didn't go with the ultimate player
yeah Indians won't go out to get
something they can make at home so okay
all right we got two we got two brown
babies I checked so it it's it's a
decision you make when opening up about
something like that yeah why did you
choose to
you know to me comedy is about
vulnerability and letting people in and
if I'm gonna
ask you to take an hour of your time to
to hear my jokes I wanna I wanna share a
secret with you guys yeah yeah you know
and it's it's about sometimes sharing
things that you're too embarrassed to
talk about I really like being a your
wife because she seems to call you out
and very she drops a couple f-bombs I
said does she really talk to you that
way and you said yes she does oh yeah
yeah she's a co-writer when she thinks
you've crossed the line yeah she calls
you out she seems to keep you in check I
like her she's my Gujarati Jiminy
Cricket he's always checking to make
sure I'm doing the right thing yeah
let's talk about the Saudi uh government
stuff you've been openly critical of the
Saudi government uh and then you got a
letter in the mail uh from a fan what
was in it what was the reaction yeah I
don't know who sent it but after a
couple of our episodes somebody found
out where we lived
there was an envelope it was filled with
white powder to your house yeah to our
house and um that's scary yeah it's
terrifying and and you know that's when
you kind of realize there is there is
blowback to your your material and
there's there's been things that you
know I didn't realize what happened you
know went after the Saudis Jared Kushner
yeah um even even Nobel Peace Prize
winner Malala doesn't like me anymore
seriously oh yeah I I told a joke I said
she follows me on Instagram and I don't
follow her back and the next day she
unfollowed me on Instagram
okay so what's wrong man this is real
this is real yeah this is one thing to
do with social media but then when
you're receiving mail to your house
right like how do you do I mean yeah
does that mean when you now write a joke
do you run it through multiple filters
one of those filters being is this going
to lead to me or my family being in
danger
I think one of the things that I think
about now is hey you're saying something
it's going to be in 190 countries and
now because of the internet everyone's
gonna be able to see it if you stand by
this right and the repercussions that
may come with it so it's like number one
is it funny number two absolutely yeah
and do I stand by it and the
repercussions that could come with it
but that's the beauty of this special
which by the way guys Reed Hastings
who's a big cheese over at Netflix says
it's honest and then hilarious he said
one of the best specials he's ever seen
Hastings normally doesn't speak out in
that way so Kudos CEOs love the special
by the way the CEO of only fans yeah
tweeted that she loved my cheeky jokes
no I don't know I don't know if you
thought about this
I don't know I see what you did
let's talk about the joke you make about
Kumail because I think this is hilarious
because you have serious stuff and then
it goes to really funny yeah he's a
cyber bully he's a cyber bully because
let's put up the picture because you
call him out on this saying Don't Clap
at this you said this is an insult to
all brown people why this is a personal
challenge because he showed white people
what we could look like
and how dare he set the bar so high yes
you don't have that underneath I'm
barely filling up under that Freddy
Krueger sweater I'm 165 pounds away you
know so I might try to fill this up as
much as I can well you might have heard
that there's an opening coming up but
Trevor knows at Comedy Central
have you already put in a call is
anybody calling you or you even coming
do you know something I don't know the
show's no I love it I really don't I
think a lot of people are dialing in to
say hey George cheeks think about me
well there's an open seat look let's put
in the application right now because
they're going to revamp in January how
would you revamp oh this person didn't
want to know if you're interested look
I'll I'll put it this way okay I'm gonna
keep my DMs and my heart open okay one
of two things is going to happen either
The Daily Show is going to want me back
or Office Max is going to want me back
but I will be exploring my options
during the offseason you were good in
Office Max I was great the Canon inkjet
5970 right now but but but all jokes
aside when you heard that news because
it shots all of us
um what was it like working from within
and hearing that news you're talking
about seeing Trevor's dimples up close
yeah because you guys see it in 1080P I
got to see it up close he's an
incredible Talent you know I got to work
both with with Jon Stewart about Jewish
Yoda and Trevor yes international Man of
Mystery one of the funny skies in comedy
um I think I I am so honored to have
been a part of that great American
institution yeah and you know if you
think about The Daily Show on SNL those
are the two those are the two big ones
but when you heard he was leaving did
you say yay look at my car did you say
oh I'm so sorry to hear easily I
actually I was I just I chatted with him
I'm like man I'm so glad you you're
doing it on your terms and yeah and
you're following your heart that's
really what when a veteran receiver
walks off the field when I played I
wanted his position I told Coach put me
in the game
oh okay well listen I don't I don't have
I don't have sherry redstone's number I
can I can give him a call look you guys
know powerful people let's see how the
king's gesture does right it's a very
funny hour yeah you got two kids now uh
does that change the way you do jokes I
mean do you think you don't qual that
don't qualify anymore well yeah I mean I
I definitely think about this I'm
everything I say is now going to be on
the internet etched in Amber and so one
day my daughter is gonna see what Daddy
was saying yeah
good luck whatever you decide yeah